Diamond of diamond and silk has died
what so we have Michael Morrison it's
reposting a truth from Trump really bad
news Republicans and frankly all
Americans are beautiful Diamond of
diamond and silk has just passed away at
her home in the state she loved so much
North Carolina silk was with her all the
way and at her passing there was no no
better team anywhere anytime Diamond's
death was totally unexpected probably
her big Precious Heart just plain gave
out rest in peace our magnificent
Diamond you'll be greatly missed and we
have this from the official diamond and
silk Twitter account right here they say
the world just lost a true angel warrior
Patriot for Freedom love and Humanity
please respect the privacy of diamonds
family Memorial ceremony TBA
contributions towards preserving
diamonds Legacy error only being
accepted the following link
man that's crazy this just happened they
posted this two minutes ago so somebody
somebody posted in the Super Chat
um that diamond and took it passed away
I immediately went to fact check it was
about five minutes ago I saw the post
from the office of Mike couldn't get up
truth social because truth social blocks
you from viewing posts unless you like
are logged in or whatever uh and then
diamond and Silk's official account just
posted it so rest in peace man big
bummer sad to hear it yeah yeah
it's horrible I didn't know her I didn't
know anything about them this first I've
heard of them what uh what are their
personalities what are their what are
their what are they known for
Sport and drum I guess yeah whenever
you're a black woman and you support
Trump openly I mean yeah you're a
celebrity
overnight because you don't see it as we
like unicorns so whenever a black person
supports a Republican president yeah
amazing yeah yeah I was gonna say Pariah
I mean you probably you guys probably
get attacked like crazy like yeah as
soon as you guys came out like you
mentioned you lost fans yeah it's like I
don't know it's just being black you're
like supposed to be Democrats like
and isn't that weird that it's like the
people claim to be fighting for racism
are perpetuating exactly what they plan
to be fighting against that's because
Joe Biden picks his vice president
because she's black that's why they
picked the jokes because she black
it's just great politicians you know
what I mean but
where where that pisses off racist white
people or racist people get pissed off
if someone of another race
puts someone of their race in because
they feel like they're getting an
undercut just makes more animosity
exactly
they call us token blacks but they do it
all the time but it's okay yeah it's
like it's a double stat oh I'm gonna
pick a black one oh I'm gonna pick this
because she's black I mean ain't they
talking black you didn't get before them
to them for their qualification but they
call us token negro yeah because yeah it
feels so obvious that yeah putting
someone in a position because of their
color it's obvious right racist right
it's obvious right but the issue is that
he proclaimed it is that he's like I
promised I would have a you know woman
of color as my VP and it's like if he
just picked Kamala Harris people would
be like you think he did that as a
virtue signal they wouldn't be saying
out right like we know he did it because
he's racist it's for the black book
though that's why he's doing that's why
he's got to say it that's why the
Supreme Court he he appointed she's not
even a judge she doesn't even know what
a woman is she's not crazy yeah yeah
that girl's name I don't know you guys
know the woman's name the new Supreme
Court Justice
he's the black woman that doesn't know
what a woman is but I'll tell you one of
the most offensive things about is
Kareem Jean-Pierre is his press
secretary is just he's really bad at her
job she's horrible yeah she's going to
be because she has to laugh at Joe
Budden so yeah she's probably a great
press secretary but no she's told she's
horrible Jen's sake you knew she was
lying yeah but she was pretty good yeah
she knew how to play the game yeah and
then so it's like ah you're really
frustrated you're like come on dude if
she doesn't have that people really good
off the cuff yeah but um if she doesn't
have that paperwork in front of her to
read off of the other girl that new girl
she's blind she she's done she wouldn't
have nothing to say yeah because she
can't think for herself it's all she's
actually a token yeah it's like ESG
stuff but in government I mean it's all
the same I guess yeah that's the
weirdest thing like what's what's the
United States going to look like when
they're like okay we got rid of anybody
capable of doing the job but everybody
who is here looks like a rainbow yeah
it's like that dude still in suitcases
why did he get his dog he's still in the
suitcases right that's so weird too like
what was up with that you know anything
people were saying that he would steal
women's clothing and then get off on
wearing it in public
[Laughter]
it makes it I call him an honest
politician because like what he was
doing is just a small amount of what all
the other politicians are doing on such
a bigger level so at least he did it to
people's you know sort of face sort of
kind of not really but kind of stealing
the luggage and walking away and then
lying about it is the funniest thing
it's like bro you're on camera this is
the time
baggage when you flew why are you
grabbing people's suitcases like I think
a lot of people lose their luggage all
the time right this is and and we never
find it
how much was that bag he stole it was
like an expensive design so they
investigated that yeah yeah what is it
to me is it the company to me something
like that super expensive bags you ever
see that oh yeah oh yeah like you get a
little carry-on bag it's like a thousand
dollars yeah oh yeah yeah so he grabbed
the wrong bag man yeah he could have
grabbed that Walmart twenty dollar bag
and people would have been like that's
why he grabbed it that's right yeah he's
thinking like ooh there's gonna be a
nice dress in here I can wear yeah good
news from earlier Demar Hamlin's
released from the hospital we were
talking earlier about athletes falling
down and he had didn't say why like they
say what he had or what happened didn't
say one week after cardiac arrest he's
gave a statement he's headed home to
Buffalo with a lot of love in my heart
on my heart good for you I hope he makes
a full recovery of course but do you
think the crew will ever come out well I
think actually happened the healthier he
is the more likely the truth will come
out you think so he's the guy he's the
spokesman for what happened to him yeah
he seems like a good guy had a great
charity going and I think if something I
think he would speak the crew I'm hoping
you would a regardless but how many of
these so you know I talked about a
friend of mine who uh he he lost control
of his hands and his legs after he got
the vaccine and the doctors the doctors
told them that's what it was yeah right
yeah and and like yeah I'm not telling
you what is or isn't I'm saying like
this has literally happened okay
talk to your doctor by the way what
makes sense for you the doctors came out
later and said it was a vitamin
deficiency that's an important point of
the story so the issue is
what are you allowed or supposed to
think or how are you supposed to know
when you get conflicting stories because
here's my issue obviously a lot of
people come out and they want to blame
the vaccine and I'm like yo it's really
hard when I'm sitting in a room reading
stories and we're all at our computers
trying to figure out what's going on the
one thing I can say is sure a lot of
stories about people collapsing on
Sports Fields And while running and
doing all these things and there's
there's you know let's say hypotheses
and theories about what's going on
but we're not getting any official work
done on on investigating red flag right
there had they made it official that the
vaccine causes blood clots so I think uh
it was a fact checked on that dude but
that yeah you did I talked about it
because it was uh
here's what they said AstraZeneca and
Jonathan Johnson did get flagged for a
rare side effect of blood clots right
but the Pfizer uh Pfizer bioentec one
they said was they the study showed
strong signals of blood clots but not
evidence of causation just correlation
now here's a funny thing
they do the climate change thing for
people you know having heart attacks and
it's just a correlation yeah yeah you
guys no hey hey that was just a
correlation
yeah so you know the best thing anyone
can say is and I mean this sincerely
we don't know for sure yeah just to make
sure your doctor is up to date on all of
this information if your doctor can't
answer your questions find one who can
it's that simple because because the
media is going to censor everything
YouTube's got their rules there's
different Vang opinions all that matters
in my in my view is you have a doctor
who knows what they're talking about and
then you get sound medical advice yeah
that happened to my assistant law as
well if you couldn't she couldn't walk
she lost all this Eric Clapton yeah you
know Eric Clapton is the famous guitar
player yeah and he's like I can't use my
hands what happened and so you know one
thing I think too is if you give 400
million doses of a vaccine yeah and it's
got like a fraction like you know 0.1.01
side effect you're going to see a
thousand several thousand stories right
and it might freak you out right but the
real issue might be that just gave out
400 million doses you know what I mean
right so that's why I'm like look man I
don't want to be biased one way or the
other but obviously I think people need
to get sound medical advice from a guy
who knows all about this yeah but you
don't want to you know you don't want to
go to a doctor and he's just like oh I
don't know anything about this but
here's my advice no no go to doctor who
can be like here's the studies we saw
here's here's my opinion on them and
here's my recommendation for you they
didn't do it in long-term studies though
they test dummy like yeah billions of
people and they tested six months but no
no but when they tested it whenever
someone got hurt they just kicked them
out of the trial right so that data was
skewed and we're trusting the data that
was given given by them done by them
that they're that they have no liability
for that they make a profit off of this
product while the government is not uh
Connecting the Dots here or
investigating any of this that just
thinks not just that they're not
investigating it it's that President
Biden seven hours ago tweeted out
everyone six months and up should get
their updated cultivating vaccine
coveted vaccine like why is a non-doctor
telling people to get covered vaccines
six months old this is what bothers me
about the whole thing is that I can sit
here all day and be like find a doctor
who's right for you and Joe Biden
doesn't have to right and these
celebrities don't have to and The Rock
doesn't have to right these other big
YouTubers don't have to and I'm like
wait man how is it that if you say
something like I'm not a doctor but my
recommendation is not to take this
medication it's like oh we're gonna ban
you but this guy who's at a doctor is
saying pull into a 7-Eleven parking lot
let a stranger inject you that's the
craziest thing to me no my right I got
into it I talk about the story I got
into it on Twitter because Casey neistat
he's a cool dude he said you know go get
the vaccine or whatever and I responded
with like go talk to a doctor and figure
out exactly yeah and then the response I
got from him was like he's like that's
weird I did I just drove into a park
into a parking lot and got it through
the window and I was like yo
he also he also said vote for Hillary
Clinton and he did work for CNN so he
doesn't have the best judgment there he
did say he regretted endorsing Hillary
Clinton I don't think he's a bad dude I
just think I'd say like this when Trump
said he was going to come out with a
vaccine and he said he was going to
happen by the end of the year I said I
ain't taking that [ __ ] so did Kamala
Harris exactly yeah but you know the
whole thing about that vaccine when he
first came out if you take the vaccine
you don't have to social distance you
don't have to wear a mask
to normal yeah back to normal it was a
great vaccine stop the curve yeah yeah
whatever and then people's getting a
vaccine and people were still getting
sick Oh you if you're vaccinated you
still got a social distance and wear a
mask I'm like wait a minute right that
was the problem how effective is this
vaccine if you still have to well 100
safe and effective according to the CEO
advisor and then 98 95 93 92 you see the
news articles going all the way down
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8 pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time